when I first started the game I made an
account name and in Danish what it was
called the bad one and then I just
started playing more and more and then
when I got up and higher higher ranking
and I joined European teams they didn't
like my name because it wasn't Danish so
I had to change name
beautiful used the distortion and trashy
just body-slammed flashes it's
introduced me to the game but at that
time I didn't actually play it
he just only showed me the game but at
this time I was playing a game called
TrackMania which is like a car game I
was actually playing it on a pretty high
level like in the top of of Europe and
some of the guys I was playing it with
started playing D so we were just like
Ashley trolling around the league at
some times and then it just kinda went
from that like I was playing more and
more and then suddenly I started
becoming better at the game so and then
League of Legends kind of took over from
Romania some of my friends knew it
someone from my friends didn't mostly
like girls didn't know I was playing cuz
it was pretty a turn-off in the
beginning that you were playing video
games all day more of my friends know
now most of my friends actually know it
since now I live of it and live in
Germany my parents on the other hand
were pretty supportive they always told
me to kind of go with whatever I felt
like we're gonna prove us wrong to
change the corruption land suck up some
trashy combo up perfectly and trashy
secures the kill at some point I got up
and like high rankings and it kind of
went from that like then I started
joining teams by playing competitive in
Denmark first with some of my friends
and we were winning some tournaments in
Denmark and I got kinda got a feel for
it and I wanted to compete I love
competing so I got picked up by a Europe
like a European team and got to travel
around Europe and play tournaments and I
really just enjoyed it so I pursued 2/3
dream of going pro
she will come to help out so even if
chachi could have won that she will
finish this off killing I was having a
rough time in Europe most teams were
kinda not choosing me over our junglers
at the time and I kinda felt like I had
won I can had one chance back and that
was to take it off from America and just
kind of just go with it and see how far
I could get
but they're gonna close the game out
enemy eSports welcome to the North
American League Championship Series all
the guys in enemy were great guys and we
were working well together even though
it ended up pretty poorly with us
getting relegated in the end and our
season was pretty bad in the LCS I
learned a lot about myself and the time
and a lot about what I wanted to do with
myself in my life and that's kind of why
I decided to go back to Europe
the spring flood was kinda we went into
it and we only had like one week prior
to the start with yamato as coach with
time I realized that I was actually
really coolest about the game honestly
what I should do in the game it took a
long time for us not only me but also
the other players to kind of understand
how we should play the game that's why
in a lot of the games it was rough for
us we lost a lot of games of like basic
stuff that we failed and then it just
looked really ugly in the games for me
and the Russell team it was a lot of
like learning experience and we were
just really focusing on getting every
like learning as much as possible every
week and of course when you lose a lot I
have lost so much games in LCS and a lot
of people have seen me as a really bad
player in the past criticism was very
very rough for me I I lost a lot of my
confidence in myself from the criticism
and it can it can make you really
depressed
honestly it's definitely not an easy
life like you you have to be very strong
mentally to be able to compete for a
long time but what made me going is that
my team believed in me and my coach
believed in me this is a top-tier team
and they're looking to improve they have
a sense of polish on their play they are
one of the few teams I think that has a
lot of different styles of play like we
can play the top we can play to mid we
can play to both kind of like it like t2
is trying to do with expect as well
where they they want to be able to play
at every side of the map and that's what
we do too and that makes us a bit more
unexpected like people can converse and
predict what we're gonna do in pick and
been etc so we are just working well
together we have a good environment and
I think we were just doing our best
every day
you